so
just some numbers the video got about
130 million views in seven days which is
crazy i think i i believe ben you can
fact check me on this i believe 130
million views is more than what the
actual squid games got on netflix now
netflix is a paid service and whatever
but like and people watched uh like
multiple episodes yeah 12 hours of
footage it's yes it's still amazing the
fact that it's comparable the fact that
somebody just watched the show was like
oh yeah we'll do like a backyard version
of that and got 130 million people to
watch is insane so uh he spent three and
a half million on it just to kind of put
this in perspective
um
that's basically half the cost of a 30
second super bowl commercial
wow really did you have a sponsor
it was fully paid i believe fully paid
for by brawl stars the the big the super
popular mobile game so if you look in
the arena where was where it was hosted
it's a giant brawl stars arena they have
a huge logo that was in every shot and
so for brawl stars this such a smart
move they basically paid half the cost
of a super bowl ad
got more viewership than a super cause
you get 130 million people the video is
like 20 minutes long 27 minutes long
versus a 30 second clip and this is an
epic thing that's going to get shared
and then they could take this content
repurpose it for ads or anything else
they wanted to do after the fact if they
wanted to so really smart you know for
brawl stars three million dollars is
probably their daily uh what is a one
day of ad spend on facebook or something
stars is owned by supercell and
supercell's like the the biggest game um
the bishop yeah and so if i i don't know
if this is how it would have worked if
i'm mr beast i think he could have so he
would have gotten supercell to pay for
the whole thing so three and a half
million dollars i bet he also would have
gotten another like five hundred
thousand dollar just like there's a
vague on top yeah just like just for
that and then they would have probably i
would have said to them also i'm going
to keep youtube ads on this right and mr
b i get all of it and so if mr beast is
getting
130 million views in the first seven
days and if you do maybe four dollars
per cpm that's around half a million
dollars that he got in the first week
plus i believe his deal is gonna be a
lot better than four dollars cpm uh
because he's the number he's like you
know one of the faces of youtube these
guys have custom negotiated deals that i
would bet a lot of money is better than
the standard kind of four to five
dollars what do you think it is
i bet he's getting closer to 10 cpm so
if it's 10 that's 1.3 million
yeah and just in a week in a week plus
according to our notes it looks like he
got 10 000 new subscribers
sorry i'm sorry oh my god 10 million new
subscribers in the first week and a
normal week is 400 000 subscribers so he
is 20x to subscriber growth so so what
does this do
he's continues to be the content leader
he gets 10 million new subscribers and
those people are gonna get notified for
his next video he makes a million
dollars on ads he gets the whole thing
paid for by a sponsor
and this is a great example of something
we've talked about before we talked
about this with elon when elon does epic
stuff like i'm going to go to mars we
talked about it with i forgot the guy's
name mark lazary or whoever it was
that's building that epic train
train system uh in america uh i i ranted
about disney uh disneyland last week
because again when you shoot for these
epic projects things that get people
inspired and excited
it's it seems like it's harder to pull
off but in many ways it's easier to pull
off because you'll get talent to pour in
because they want to be a part of
something bold you'll get sponsors to
pour in because they want to bet on this
this epic thing that's going to happen
they know that it's going to get a lot
of visibility and so and you get your
own motivation to get out of bed every
day because you're working on something
that's so so grand that you know you're
more motivated everybody does their best
work and people tune in to watch which
is like so ben just looked it up 140
million 142 million people watched squid
games on netflix 132 million watched uh
beast games on youtube so about the same
one to one so you get disproportionate
prizes
when you go fish in a part of the pond
that nobody else is fishing because
everyone else thinks the water is too
deep and it's too scary over there the
rewards are like disproportionate even
to the effort and the work that goes in